Speaker 1: This is beyond parody. Donald Trump is
having such trouble doing like normal interviews
lately that he is increasingly relegated to
doing whack job interviews. The latest is with
conspiracy theorist Dinesh D'Souza, and it is,
quite frankly, beyond parody. Dinesh D'Souza is
increasingly a darling of the conspiracy. Right,
that believes Donald Trump was actually the winner
of the 2020 election. Dinesh D'Souza made the
film at 2000 meals. This is a completely farcical,
obviously completely debunked film that makes
almost un falsifiable claims based on mobile
phone geolocation data. To argue that because
there were people with mobile phones more or
less near ballot drop boxes at different times
of day during the early voting period in 2020,
it is clear that they were carrying like mules.
Remember, that's the idea. They were mules for
thousands or tens of thousands of fraudulent
ballots that they were doing massive dumps
with into the drop boxes. There's no evidence for
any of it. Widely debunked. Watch the film if you
want to blow 2 hours and then research each of
the claims and you will find that it is vacant
and vapid. But Trump loves it. So Trump agreed
to be interviewed by Dinesh D'Souza. And Donald
Trump's lies are getting more and more sick
and more and more disconnected from reality,
if you can imagine that in this first clip, Donald
Trump claims some people voted 28 times on the
same day in 2020. This is a claim for which there
is no evidence. There isn't a little evidence.
There isn't some evidence.
There is no evidence for
this claim. And Dinesh D'Souza just nods along.
Speaker 2: And then, of course, they voted six,
seven, eight times here as much as they could
in the local area. Some of the people went back,
I guess they said 28 times, and now they go
to vote at different places with, you know,
numerous votes. But they can't they can't
put in a thousand because it wouldn't be
a you know, wouldn't look. Right. Right.
Speaker 1: You they voted 28 times because
voting a thousand times would raise suspicions.
But voting 28 times was fine. Under whose names?
They never answer that question.
Just the most fundamental. If I
David Pakman try to vote 28 times in
28 different places at each place,
I have to give some name and it has to
be someone who hasn't already voted,
but it's registered in that particular precinct.
How would I get the names? What names that I give?
They don't tell us. No. The people voted 28 times.
Speaker 2: They're very smart. You know,
they go in with five votes, six votes,
seven votes, and then they go to another
one. But it adds up to millions of votes. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Absolutely delusional. And again,
it's the blind leading the blind. Dinesh
D'Souza, just nodding, nodding, nodding,
nodding along. In the next clip, Donald Trump
raises the conspiracy theory that William Barr,
his own attorney general. This is not, you know,
Merrick Garland, the Trump's own attorney general,
William Barr, covered up the election
fraud because of fear he had of Democrats.
Speaker 2: It was wonderful. They didn't
even do a genuine bill. Barr was afraid to
be impeached. He was petrified of being impeached.
Speaker 1: And look at Dinesh D'Souza. Not along
to something so completely absurd. When William
Barr had almost no time left in this office at
the time that he refused to participate in
the lies and the delusions. Why would that
be? William Barr's fear in November, December
and January of 2020 and 2021, respectively.
Speaker 2: The Democrats said they were
going to impeach him. They went very big
on the impeachment thing with him. And all of a
sudden we have an attorney general who
is afraid to talk about his saying, oh,
the election was just wonderful and it wasn't.
Speaker 1: You know, William Barr was in the
George H.W. Bush administration much earlier
in his career. He didn't seem afraid of anybody
or anything there. And then he had a lot of
work that he did in the private sector. And
you would think if he had a time to be afraid
of Democrats when it might have damaged his
future private industry career, it would have
been when he was working for George H.W. Bush
and he wasn't afraid. Then why would he be afraid
at the end of 2020, the start of 2021, near the
end of his career? It just doesn't make any sense
whatsoever. And then lastly, Donald Trump saying
Fox News is not what it used to be. But
listen carefully to the language he uses.
Speaker 3: Talking about.
Speaker 2: It's much different than
it was when I first ran Fox. It's a lot different.
Speaker 1: Talking about Fox has changed. Fox is
not doing for Trump when he first ran and I know
it says it sounds like Trump is saying when I
first ran Fox, what he means is when I first ran,
Fox was different. What Trump means is what was
ultimately a 100% sycophant brown nosing channel.
Fox News is now only about 90%. They're leaving
themselves the escape hatch, the eject button
in case Ron DeSantis or someone else ultimately
becomes the nominee. But that means you are on
Trump's naughty list. You're no longer on the nice
list. What a pathetic interview. And Trump reduced
to being interviewed by Dinesh D'Souza. What a
just totally humiliating display. And as usual, as
usual, Trump only wants friendly interviews. And
if it's anything but friendly, sometimes he'll
hang up. Remember, with NPR, he'll attack the
interviewer. The right way is to ask Trump the
questions, tee up softballs for him to knock out
of the park with lies and then just nod. Dinesh
D'Souza Really? You know, the right likes to use
the term un-PC. Dinesh D'Souza Really playing
the NBC folks. Remember that our YouTube channel
is heading towards 2 million subscribers. This is
an insane number for a little old show like ours.
And the most important piece of data I have for
you, we have nearly 3 million existing viewers who
aren't subscribed. And as I've been talking about
this, more and more of them email me and they say,
David, you know, I watch you every day. I checked,
I'm not a subscriber. I didn't need to subscribe.
YouTube was already feeding me all your videos.
Very, very important. If you were one of these,
we call them the 2.8 hours. There's about 2.8
million people last month who watched our videos
but are not subscribed on YouTube. You can help
us get to the 2 million subscriber number like
tomorrow, if just you fine folks who watch but
don't subscribe were to hit that subscribe button.
We could be there overnight. YouTube.com slash The
David Pakman Show subscribe free. It is free and I
will address this in the voicemail segment today.
We'll take a quick, quick break and be right back